first of all do you believe we need to
go to Mars Oh so why of course
I've been collecting reasons for the
last 40 years I mean it's not only the
science and possible return on
investment but it's exploration and
great civilizations explore and then as
Elon said this could be a hedge against
future catastrophe so do you believe
that we could face an extinction event
here on earth and that we need to go to
Mars to survive well the the dinosaurs
needed a space program right so it could
happen to us although personally I'm
more interested in the science we could
do if we get people to Mars francois
what are your thoughts on this ago and
what do you make of Musk's idea that it
will be easier to set up a city there
than to just set up going back and forth
no it's a very good point and I'm sure
at some point yeah we have a city on
Mars and beside it on musk and SpaceX
there's already a good dozen of startups
working on the enabling technology that
will facilitate the building of that
city so it makes completely sense of
course Scott the plan that musk laid out
do you see any holes in it or does this
look like it could work well there's
nothing in there that's dilithium
crystals or the transporter beam it's
all in principle plausible and pieces
but it's at the scale that nobody has
ever attempted before he's talking about
a rocket that's four times the thrust of
the Saturn five so will it scale up who
knows but I wouldn't bet against Elon
he's been successful
do you see NASA being a partner here of
sorts mean NASA obviously is a
completely different view of why we need
to get there you know more for
exploration a manned mission in the
future musk is going for an all-out
civilization right now I think that this
is extremely important and I think that
it would be a public-private partnership
and maybe an international partnership
as well I don't see this as being just
the US and SpaceX so Francois talk to us
about the funding of this obviously it's
going to be extremely expensive you know
by traditional or conventional means it
costs 10 billion dollars a person to get
out there but Elon Musk wants to drop
that to 200,000
dollars a person what do you think about
his proposal to investors so I think
that is it's going to be a multi-step
business plan and as we can compare that
missions with the International Space
Station's it got funded even if at the
beginning it was only making sense for
research purposes as soon as there would
be a couple of people on March maybe we
will find some interesting new new type
of materials or new property that may be
formed for large corporates for large
corporates it would make sense to invest
and put a lab or a laboratory or a
research center on Mars and so they
could then participate in the funding of
the next step and at the next stage and
thence in 10 to 20 years when we'll have
improved the the engines and reduce the
cost to a week and a couple of thousands
and and read of dollars to go there yeah
that would be another business case for
more people like us to go there so it
will take time but I will see that more
in a step-by-step approach like we see
for the disturb that we are investing in
or supporting yes